apparently actor Robert De Niro you may
have heard this is in the middle of a
lawsuit against a former assistant who
embezzled money from him and get this
binge-watched fifty five episodes of
friends in four days while on the job
I'll say that again fifty five episodes
of friends in four days while at work
now that seems like a lot to probably
all of you but I was thinking it myself
I know someone who could blow that
number away someone who watches a ton of
television at work is rarely paying
attention to me I'm talking about my
assistant Sonam obsessive
so Monday Monday on the show I challenge
Sona to beat the record of watching
binge watching 55 episodes at work of
friends in four days she said no problem
without skipping a beat and this is for
real this is not we're not making this
up she has been watching friends since
Monday so let's go live to Sohn his desk
and check on her progress Sona
sonna you have your watching friends
right now you've been watching friends
since Monday and it's on your computer
right now is that right it is I have
season 5 episode 17 okay and you started
you didn't start at the beginning how
many episodes have you watched so far
I've watched I wrote it down so that I
could say this cuz I can't do the math
uh it's I'm on my 42nd episode you're on
your 42nd episode let me ask you a
question you look down for a second are
you also doing what you always do is
watch is are you playing are you right
now doing Sudoku there was only some way
I could get rid of you uh but yes I am
also still doing my normal duties which
is my suit I do the New York Times
pseudo puzzles I do easy medium and hard
ok and if I do all three of them I call
it the trifecta
all right good for you sona which
episode are you watching now season 5
episode 7 what is it which one oh it's
the one with Rachel's inadvertent case
that's when she accidentally kissed the
guy at Ralph Lauren and it was very
awkward it's okay Oh Phoebe's dating a
cop and she's telling Monica and we got
it that's good that's fine so what are
some of the things that you've had to
sort of blow off that you would not you
know work-related things in order to
watch all these episodes of friends well
you've asked me to you know pick up food
for you or have someone pick up food
freeze I asked you to get me a turkey
wrap a turkey spinach wrap today for
lunch yeah I didn't do that no you did
she really she really didn't do that I
didn't get any lunch today
oh no it really isn't but it's I'm glad
that America's seeing what I see every
day and have seen for 10 years okay
we're going to check back in with Sona
tomorrow when I think no doubt you were
going to smash this record formerly held
by Robert De Niro that's really her
[Applause]